[Musique]
je m'appelle Alexandra javorski je suis
créatrice de bijoux en bout de Chouchou
et de maroquinerie la gamme c'est typo
chouchou une gamme unique à la Réunion
moi je vais créer donc des bijoux donc
des bracelets des boucles d'oreilles
voilà des bagues et les produits stars
donc c'est le bracelet Ginko en acier
inoxydable et également le bracelet
Monster donc ça ce sont vraiment des
produits qui partent comme des petits
pains qui sont ce sont les chouchous des
clients en fait moi je vais travailler
les chouchous donc des vieux chouchous
que Miramas dans dans le champ
donc mini et puis après midi
il fait sa chalet et mi teintes aller
après mes travail sur les bijoux voilà
avec des petits gabarits de façon à
présenter sur les bijoux en acier
inoxydable
alors le salon de l'agriculture c'est
pour montrer qu'avec du chouchou enfin
on met le chouchou en l'air dans le
temps longtemps on utilise la page
chouchou ben je veux montrer qu'on peut
avec la peau de Chouchou également faire
des beaux produits et matériels réunion
voilà
[Musique]